okay got put on this up you got there
now one shoulder
walking up to the finish line right now
I mean it
all day and our swag everybody online
make them a little bit more happier
right I got you on the shirt that you
missed you you I got you already know
you already know what's coming future
sides right now I gotta figure out wait
a 2x I'm in the 3x
yes thank you thank you thank you didn't
take it oh it is good there's no problem
no problem looking for next week's big
man are you doing and then out to the
big guys first I want big guys to get it
first
what's going on oh yeah you don't hear
this [ __ ] and put it on stop playing
[Music]
guys we'll get all the big guys out the
way first I'm gonna bring it back this
way
what's going on guys how's everybody
today they see bongos
oh when I told you what I told you it's
movie right having fun I'm in a great
town man you'll see the screams out of
control last night he's out of control
Mike Ibarra we is out of control last
night oh my god guys everybody's gonna
see the video I had a whole smoked best
one yesterday I wasn't man he was like
hose down the downs the man check it is
up there I tagged you in it I gotta give
her I gotta give up some more shirts oh
my god what sizes do you either you look
like you launched sorry my bad extra
large I think I have an extra large we I
was giving them out as I was walking
down I have to get to the ladies thank
you
I do apologize what sizes do you go in
is over there you go in a joke what size
are you man yeah could you check here
cuz I believe I have your size in there
right yeah there's a large keep going
I'm know you in there I know I put a
medium or small in there there you go oh
what's going on girl I am so sorry yes I
went I told you I was gonna see you
right could you please pick out of the
paint
ladies please
I got you later on checked out there
perfect suicides that focus I told you
I've got you Delilah you're my stream
every day right I got I did 210 on the
coast yeah yeah I put the videos up I
just pulled in and drove around this way
beep the horn came back yeah you put
that on that's you besides you know
you're not you're not good looking out
on that shirt
there you go there you go you ain't yet
we're exciting it good I'm glad you
excited Oh purple purple purple purple
who's a medium I need a medium I need a
medium you look like you'll meet him
you're medium why are you not reaching
your hands out for free stuff man what
is going on you mmediately there you go
look at that see you got your hands full
she's looking at you why you folding
your hands up he's supposed to be taking
anything I can give you let me see let
me see
what's this was this was this was this
was this was this a large a large nobody
you did you go I've never seen this in
my life
no this is the last pack shirt movies
that pack extra large there you go I
want everybody have a great time today I
want you to like subscribe and follow
iron Lords podcast where we giving out
free games we got um ant the ruler
handing out raffle the first Sunday back
after e3 at 1:00 p.m.
we're gonna be giving out games you're
not gonna stop until we get three
winners three so we're gonna keep going
and we're gonna be live raffle drawings
so when he hands you longer to keep the
attention that's the man that's the man
he got us here today
that's the man
turn it over